donc la liste de 24 joueurs pour les
quatre matches qui nous attendent france
danemark roissy france autriche france
et france croatie
gardien de but alphonse areola hugo
loris
mike maignan
défenseur
jonathan klaus
lucas digne
lukasz hernandez théo hernandez
presnell kimbembe jules koum des
benjamins pava
wiljan saliba
raphaël varane
milieu de terrain
matteo guendouzi
boubacar camara boubacar pardon camara 1
go l'eau quand et
adrien rabiot
aurélien jomini
attaquants
wissam ben yedder
karim benzema
kingsley coman
moussa diaby
antoine griezmann
killian un bape et
christopher nkoum coup
voilà